- I have to say this though.
So your friends are different from mine,
because you shared this photo (laughs)
of you and Brooke Shields as girls.
So y'all knew each other as young kids?
- Isn't that funny?
We grew up together.
- What?
- Isn't that wild?
- Yes!
- I know,
we were in grade school together
and we were very close
for a period of time.
- Oh my gosh.
- And this was on a vacation
we went to Howl Caverns
together in upstate New York.
- Oh my!
- I remember when that picture was taken
and we have a very sweet friendship
because we've known each
other our entire lives.
- Yeah.
- You know?
We're not in contact all the time,
but when we run into
each other occasionally
it's always so nice,
'cause we knew each other-
- I have those friends that you've known
since you were a kid.
- As little children.
- Yeah.
- Like, I remember
the stuffed animals on her bed.
She remembers, you know,
parents who are no longer alive.
You know, we have a deep
connection that way.
- That's so cool to have that kind.
Especially with you, both
being in the limelight
and just being able talk-
- Yeah!
- With that as well.
- Absolute.
No, that comes in very handy.
- Yeah!
- Yeah, you have to have the safe people.
- I just thought that was so
random, I was like wait, what?
- Isn't that wild?
- Yes!
- I know.
- I was like, you childhood
was different than mine.
(Laura and Kelly laughing)
- I didn't go to school
with a dozen celebrities.
(Laura and Kelly talking over each other)
- I was like, wow, that's so random.